florent est à nouveau en deuil depuis un
an c'est un ancien de chez moi de ma
brigade qui je travaillais pas en deux
ans et c'est quelqu'un de
juste fabuleux qui a repris les
commandes de la cuisine depuis plus d'un
an et qui est très axée sur le produit
est avant tout dans ma façon de
travailler à mende la façon très fière
florent l'important c'est de vraiment
rester le terroir dans lequel on est
respecté l'environnement respecter les
produits il ya aucun intérêt aujourd'hui
de faire des produits qui vont venir de
métropole et pour les kiwaniens d'asie
j'ai une cuisine martiniquaise la chance
d'avoir aujourd'hui un terroir qui est
très riche en produits aussi bien aux
fruits en légumes en crustacés en
poissons en viande quand il ya 100
terroir qui est très riche
il faut vraiment revisité réinterpeller
interpréter et s'approprier les produits
de la martinique vous me portez sur la
castration gastronomique donner du
plaisir donner du plaisir aux gens du
partage et c'est vraiment les valeurs
qui me tenait à coeur à l'étoile elle
est venue j'ai jamais travaillé pour
l'étoile c'est ce qui est important
c'est que de la neige est ainsi
récompensé certitude mais on ne comptera
pas pour les thoniers enfin qu'en tout
cas pour mon cas - le but c'est vraiment
de prendre du plaisir ce que je fais
j'ai la chance de tous les matins de me
lever et être heureux de ce que je fais
tous les jours et c'est que l'on prend
du plaisir on doit forcément du plaisir
et c'est à ce moment là où michelin est
venu récompenser aussi une cuisine
généreuse d'une gourmande cuisine qui
respecte et mon terroir
mon aquitaine et la gironde qui m'est
cher et ça c'est très important